entonces directo hasta parís el
epicentro de lo que fue esta
intervención del presidente ucraniano
que se dirigió a los parlamentarios de
manera de videoconferencia allá está a
erika olavarría a erika estábamos
hablando de la previa pero entonces
hagamos un resumen de lo que fue esta
intervención del presidente silencio
si raúl a buenas tardes bueno fue
recibido como ha ocurrido en otros
lugares no es cierto con standing
ovation aplausos de pie pero
personalmente me pareció que esta
intervención fue más corta que en otros
lugares y tuvo menos referencias
históricas por ejemplo en lo que
respecta a la historia de francia
recuerdo sobretodo la batalla de verdad
que opuso a alemania ya francia durante
la primera guerra mundial en 1916 dijo
los bombardeos que atacan hoy a marie
paule me recuerdan justamente la batalla
de verdad pero se dirigió sobre todo a
ese papel del líder que ha tenido el
presidente manuel macrón de mediador él
dijo primero estar muy contento de que
la demanda de ucrania de ingreso a la
unión europea ocurra durante la
presidencia francesa de la unión europea
y recordó que el presidente manuel macro
ni france en general han tenido un rol
muy importante en las negociaciones de
tipo normandía que sentaron a la mesa al
presidente excelencia al presidente
ucraniano con vladimir putin él dijo
francia ya asentó una vez a rusia a
hablar de paz ojalá que lo pueda hacer
nuevamente pero para ello para renunciar
sobre toda esa aspiración de ucrania de
formar parte de la otan a dijo selenski
es necesario que hay un nuevo sistema de
paz y garantía en el mundo de que los
países pequeños y quizás más débiles y
vecinos de rusia como ucrania no sean
invadidos por el gigante ruso para ello
que hay un nuevo sistema de seguridad
internacional y que sea obviamente el
liderado por francia también hizo
mención en este mismo rol de mediador y
de lucha de francia por los valores
universales a el emblema oa la lema de
este país libertad igualdad fraternidad
y como tú decías mencionó a las empresas
francesas que aún se encuentran en
territorio ruso sacó aplausos en ese
momento cuando volvió a recordar que se
pusieran más sanciones contra rusia él
dijo bueno y que se vayan que salgan de
rusia las empresas dijo renault legua me
hablan y o sea la cadena de
supermercados así que grosso modo esos
fueron los puntos más importantes de
este discurso del precedente selenski
aquí esa solicitud de mediación francesa
y obviamente ese dedo apuntando a las
empresas francesas que siguen siguen
ganando dinero en el territorio ruso y
obviamente a esa incorporación que
espera se sabe que es larga pero que al
menos comienza ahora bajo la presidencia
francesa incorporación de ucrania en la
unión europea solicitud raúl